if I believe what I say I do which is
that I'm the ultimate judge during an
executioner of my own self-esteem then
I'm the only person who can say good job
or not and unfortunately I have
incredibly high standards and so I can
either just always feel like a failure
because I always fall short of my own
standards or I can create a standard
that I I willingly and consciously
accept which is that I will do enough
work that there is nothing left to be
done and that means that I can also do
fewer things which means I have to be
more selective about the things that I
choose to do but when I do them they
will be done well and they will be done
right